estás viendo una exhibición de globos
aerostáticos y estás interesado en saber
a qué velocidad se está elevando un
globo aerostático específico para esto
cuentas con cierta información conoces
el punto preciso desde donde inició su
despegue este globo aerostático subió
verticalmente y también sabes pues lo me
diste que estás ubicado a 500 metros del
punto de despegue estás ubicado a 500
metros del punto de despegue y también
has podido medir el ángulo de elevación
desde tu posición hacia el globo
aerostático hay instrumentos para eso no
sé un teodolito o algún tipo de
dispositivo electrónico no soy
especialista en esto pero bueno
pudiste medir este ángulo con respecto
al horizontal el ángulo de elevación del
globo aerostático y sabes que es y sobre
cuatro radiales o 45 grados vamos a
dejar la medida en radiales pues cuando
tomamos derivadas de funciones
trigonométricas se supone que el ángulo
está medido en radiales y también sabes
razón a la que este ángulo está
cambiando este ángulo cambia entonces
cambia a 0.2 radiales por minuto
0.2 radiales por minuto y la pregunta
que quiere responder mientras ves el
globo es a qué velocidad se está
elevando el globo aerostático en ese
momento cuando el ángulo de elevación
este ángulo que forma la horizontal y la
línea de visión del globo aerostático es
y sobre 4 radiales y está cambiando a
razón de 0.2 radiales por minuto tenemos
entonces que sabemos y que nos están
preguntando pero conocemos que el ángulo
teta es igual a ti cuartos radiales este
ángulo aquí le estoy llamando teta teta
igual aquí cuartos y también conocemos
la razón a la que cambia este ángulo
teta voy a ponerlo aquí pues al amarillo
de teta en dt es igual a 0.2 radiales
por minuto y que queremos encontrar
queremos encontrar la razón a la cual la
altura del globo aerostático está acá
y la razón a la cual se está elevando el
globo y si le llamamos esta altura h
entonces lo que queremos encontrar es de
h en de t es la pregunta cuánto es de h
en de te queremos obtener entonces una
relación entre de hdt detecta en dt y
quizás theta si es que la necesitamos
otra manera de ver esto es si obtenemos
una relación entre h y theta la
derivamos con respecto al tiempo podemos
obtener una relación entre esto que
tenemos aquí entonces cuál es la
relación entre theta y h bueno si
hacemos trigonometría básica aquí
sabemos que este cateto es opuesto a
teta y este acá es el adyacente a teta
sabemos qué cateto opuesto y cateto
adyacente se relacionan a través de la
tangente del ángulo escribamos lo por
acá tangente de teta la tangente de tdt
es igual al cateto opuesto que es h este
es el cateto opuesto tangente de teta es
igual a h sobre el cateto adyacente
no cambia es igual a 500 ya tenemos
entonces la relación entre theta y h y
ahora para obtener una relación entre
teta de teta de hdd perdón teta de tdt
la deriva de teta con respecto al tiempo
y la derivada de h con respecto al
tiempo lo que tenemos que hacer es
derivar esta expresión implícitamente
con respecto a que hagámoslo dejar de
mover h sobre 500 para que pueda tener
espacio y te pueda mostrar el operador
de hdt respecto ya está entonces vamos a
tomar la derivada con respecto al tiempo
a ambos lados de en dt de la tangente de
teta es igual a de en dt de h sobre 500
cuál es entonces la derivada con
respecto a t d tangente de teta bueno
vamos a aplicar aquí la regla de la
cadena
primero tomaremos la derivada de
tangente de teta con respecto a z la
ayuda de tangente de 30 con respecto a
teta es secante cuadrada de teta y eso
por la derivada de teta
con respecto al tiempo de teta en de t
aquí estamos recordemos aplicado largo
de la cadena estamos derivando algo una
función seca no perdón estamos derivando
tangente de algo con respecto a ese algo
por la derivada de ese algo con respecto
al tiempo a ver veamos la derivada de
tangente de teta con respecto a teta por
la derivada de teta con respecto a t nos
da la derivada de tangente de teta con
respecto a t que lo que queremos cuando
indicamos con este operador queremos
tomar la derivada con respecto a t y no
tan sólo la derivada con respecto a eta
ya tenemos entonces el lado izquierdo
desde igualdad vamos a tomar la derivada
con respecto a t en el lado derecho
privada con respecto a tdh sobre 500 va
a ser simplemente 1 sobre 500 por dh en
de t la derivada de h sobre 500 con
respecto a t es simplemente 1 sobre 500
de hdt y aquí lo tenemos ya tenemos una
expresión que relaciona la razón a la
que cambia la alto
con respecto a ti con la razón a la que
cambia el ángulo con respecto a ti y con
el ángulo si sustituimos estos valores
en la expresión podemos despejar
entonces de h en dt hagamos entonces eso
hagámoslo por acá tenemos que se cante
cuadrada de teta es secante cuadrada de
pi cuartos
y cuarto 2 lo va a poner mejor con el
color que tenemos de los datos que sería
secante cuadrada de iu cuartos y eso que
multiplica a de tdt que es 0.2 entonces
por 0.2 y esto es igual a es igual a 1
sobre 500 y sólo para asegurarnos esto
lo tenemos en radiales por minuto
entonces de hdt va a estar en metros por
minuto
simplemente para checar no puse las
unidades aquí por espacio pero estamos
verificando que si se caen las unidades
entonces uno sobre 500 que multiplica aa
dh en dt ahora para despejar de hdt
multiplicamos ambos lados de la ecuación
por 500 y tenemos la razón a la que
cambia la altura va a ser igual a 500
por secante cuadrada de pi cuartos esto
es 1 sobre con seno cuadrado de pi
cuartos pueda calcular coseno clavet y
cuartos por acá que tenemos coseno de pi
cuartos es igual a raíz
sobre 2 entonces coseno cuadrado de pi
cuartos es igual raíz de 2 al cuadrado
es 2 y 2 al cuadrado es 4 esto es igual
a 2 cuartos que es igual a un medio
entonces secante cuadra de ti cuartos va
a ser igual a 1 sobre eso va a ser igual
a 2 entonces sustituyendo por acá esto
va a ser igual déjame reescribir esto
voy a abordar esto de aquí
entonces que tenemos aquí que la secante
cuadrada de pi cuartos secante quad y
cuartos esto va a ser igual a 2 por lo
que calculamos y esto multiplicado por
0.2 así que aquí tenemos 500 por 0.4
escribamos esto esto es igual a 500 por
el punto por 0.4 y esto es igual a deja
ver 4 por 500 es 2000 corremos el punto
decimal un lugar obtenemos 200 perfecto
entonces la razón a la que cambia la
altura con respecto al tiempo es igual a
200 metros
minutos aquí tenemos que de hdt es igual
a 200 metros por minuto